good morning Sunday morning
all right internet I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Reuben report it's May 23rd 2023
and I don't know why we put that cold
open in today we've been sitting on it
for a while and I thought Nancy Pelosi
nuclear explosion it's Tuesday why not
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals if you haven't joined us yet
on locals what in God's name are you
waiting for for just a few dollars a
month you can chat with me and other
viewers you can share your thoughts
about life and much more Reuben
report.locals.com and I'm very excited
for the program today because the
machine is in flux it's freaking out and
when the machine freaks out what usually
happens they try to find an identity
group generally the blacks and or the
gays and they try to scare the hell out
of them because Whitey's coming for them
or at least that's what they would like
them to believe as you probably saw it
was happening I think as we were doing
our live stream yesterday uh South
Carolina Senator Tim Scott who's been on
the show I think he's a good dude he
announced that he is running for
president jumping in uh what I would say
is becoming a pretty crowded field of
fairly decent Republicans whether you
like them all or not agree with them all
or not it's it's a group of people who
have every right to be running with
decent resumes and the rest of it so he
is in now he happens to be
a black Republican and he is about to
find out although he knows it quite well
from the last 20 years of his career
what the machine and the lefties and the
tolerant diversity people do when they
find a black Republican intent they
don't treat them particularly well this
has happened with Ice Cube with Larry
Elder Brittany greiner's finding out
about it now Byron Donald's Congressman
down here in Florida Candace Owens and
and obviously many many other people
Thomas Souls probably the at the Apex of
that situation right there so we're
going to talk a bit about how uh the
left the machine the media they want to
keep certain people oppressed or at
least with the perception of Oppression
so that they can keep handing them
handing things out to them so that they
will only vote one way
but there's another option people there
really is and it's starting to come
together before we get to all that let
me talk to you about Phoenix Capital you
know with banks collapsing and the
turbulent state of the stock markets
millions of Americans have watched their
retirement savings disappear I want to
share with you a unique investment
opportunity that's not only protecting
retirement savings but investors are
seeing consistent yields and growth
Phoenix Capital group is offering
high-value U.S oil and gas Investments
through their corporate bonds it's a way
for people to invest in energy assets
and diversify their portfolio yields
range from 8 percent to 12 percent apy
paid monthly with different
qualifications and maturity dates
Phoenix Capital group is a tech-led
Energy company owning in some of the
most lucrative basins Across America
investor Capital along with their own
Capital goes towards cash flow positive
oil and gas projects they had the choice
of offering significantly lower interest
rate and paying the difference to
middlemen but decided to break the mold
and bring stronger invest Investments
directly to investors like you these
eight to twelve percent apy corporate
bonds are higher than CDs or annuities
often more than double the typical yield
so if you're looking for an alternative
investment with sizable yields and
monthly payment options I recommend you
check out Phoenix Capital groups Bond
offerings to learn more download their
free investor guide as at PHX on
reuben.com PHX on rubin.com tell them
Dave sent you and now back to me all
right so I believe and I believe it I
believed it for quite some time that the
Stranglehold that the Democrats
the liberal media the corporate press
the cultural taste makers that the
Stranglehold that it has had on the
black community has been one of the most
dangerous things that we've had in
America for quite some time I think to
Donald Trump's credit he did a nice job
breaking through some of that nonsense
he exposed a lot of how this whole thing
works and how it has very little to do
with doing anything good for the black
community but just keeping them as a
monolithic voting segment for the
Democrats the most famous moment of that
of course was during Donald Trump's I
believe it was his second state of the
union when he talked about all-time low
Black and Hispanic unemployment and the
Congressional Black Caucus sat there
like this AOC if I'm not mistaken didn't
even show up to the speech so what it
seems to me is that the Democrats want
to keep black people thinking that they
are oppressed again that's perceived
depression not real oppression there are
no laws that stop anyone regardless of
skin color from doing anything in this
country you've got every opportunity to
pull yourself up buy your bootstraps I
know they hate that phrase but it's true
and do whatever you want in life and
some people start out with a little bit
more and some people start off with a
little bit less it's just how it is
anyway over the last couple years thanks
to I think people like Candace Owens
Like Larry Elder Thomas sold before them
etc etc and now a whole bunch of
cultural taste makers too Hollywood
people and rappers the Stranglehold does
seem to be breaking a little bit check
this out this is Ice Cube I don't know
if that's his given name but this is Ice
Cube who is a rapper on the full send
podcast telling the nelk boys how about
about how the Republicans have been more
receptive to his ideas over the last
couple years rather than the Democrats
one more thing I wanted to ask about was
um like in the 2020 when you kind of
supported Trump and stuff like that what
did you think about like because you're
Hollywood you know there's a lot of like
propaganda and stuff like that what was
that like getting Flack for that I mean
I never supported Trump
or Biden
I never asked to speak to the
Republicans or the Democrats
I created a
document called the contract with black
America that spelled out
a lot of different issues that
We Believe were the reason why it was so
much unrest after George Floyd was
killed
um the Republicans asked could they
Implement some things from the contract
in the into their proposal
and I said the document was open for
anybody
to use in any way
they desire
okay first off I'm told that Ice Cube's
real name is O'Shea Jackson that's just
a little bonus for some of you out there
uh but okay we've got something
interesting here now Ice Cube I don't
know everything about Ice Cube I'm sure
I have major differences with Ice Cube
none of that really matters he's
obviously influential in a certain set
of society and when the cities were
burning in that summer of love and the
BLM riots and George Floyd and all that
he comes up with what he called the
contract with black America now I don't
know every detail in that thing but
let's go out on a limb and say that
there was some legitimate ideas he had
some list of grievances perhaps some
solutions and he brought it to the
Republicans and the Republicans were
basically like hey this is this is kind
of interesting let's see what we can do
with that and We Know by the way that
under Trump the Republicans were doing a
bunch of things which led to that
all-time low black unemployment and
black business ownership going up and
things related to incarceration and a
whole bunch more so that's that's
interesting and it goes against the
narrative right now listen to this they
asked him about how the Democrats
responded to that very same document
I met with the Democrats the Democrats
said
we like 90 of what's in there
and we'll talk to you after the election
about it
there's like a stigma amongst like the
African-American Community to like
Republicans and stuff like that I don't
know what's going on in the
African-American Community when it comes
to that you know I mean
like
black people have
supported Democrats you know uh
overwhelmingly for 50 60 years
and and nothing has changed so
something's got to change
okay so it's pretty interesting he's
right black people have overwhelmingly
supported the Democrat Party and the
Democrat Party has done things like
welfare and handouts and all of these
things which you guys know you've
watched the show enough you've watched
enough uh interviews with Thomas Soul
Etc that these are the programs that
keep People In Perpetual poverty and not
only that but intergenerational poverty
right so if you're if you're getting
subsidized housing in a building that
the apartments should be going for three
thousand bucks but because of the color
of your skin you get it for four hundred
dollars you might not want to get out of
that and then you might also take the
other benefits and the food stamps and
things of that nature by the way that
has nothing to do with skin color you're
getting it because of skin color but
it's The Human Condition oh you're going
to give me a whole bunch of stuff
because of my skin color and I'm not
going to have to work as hard whether
you're black or white or anything else
an awful lot of people would accept that
so that is the danger it is the well
intentions although I don't think it's
well intentioned anymore it is the
well-intentioned uh liberal guilty
Democrat that has led to so much of this
so he's right Ice Cube we know that the
black community basically votes over 90
percent every election for the Democrats
and then seemingly things get worse
right so you might want to put on a
little pressure you might want to think
about it a little bit differently you
might want to realize that skin color is
not the most important thing at all and
that in a society that has individual
rights no law is stopping anyone from
doing anything related to their skin
color or sexuality or anything else you
might just want to get out there and not
ask the government for anything you
might want to listen to Ronald Reagan
and know that the government is the most
dangerous thing out there but we are
going to unpack this much more because
there was because it's really getting
nutty related to Florida because now
they fear DeSantis and they're trying to
make this place seem like the the racist
capital of the world which is just
patently ridiculous but let's talk about
moink box real quick and then we'll get
back to it you guys know that 60 percent
of U.S pork production comes from one
company owned by the Chinese and their
Hogs are given something called
ractopamine which is banned in 160
countries including China yet you find
in your grocery aisle every day well
guys there's a better way I want to tell
you about moink that is Moo plus oink
moink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door you choose the meat delivered in
every box like rib eyes chicken breasts
pork chops to salmon fillets and much
more plus you can cancel any time
there's nothing better than cooking
their meats on my big green egg on a
Friday evening Shark Tank host Kevin
O'Leary called moink's bacon the best
bacon he's ever tasted and they
guarantee you'll say oink oink I'm just
so happy and I got moist keep American
farming going by signing up at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
one of the best filet mignon you'll ever
taste but for a limited time
m-o-i-n-kbox.com rubenbox.com Reuben and
now back to me okay
so why is it that a guy like Ice Cube
unrelated to iced tea have they ever
worked together has Ice Cube and ice tea
ever work together you do not know
Phoenix has no idea you like that Frank
Sinatra too don't you anyway uh whether
Ice Cube and iced tea work together or
not why is Ice Cube saying this why is
Ice Cube saying what what most of us
know the handout thing doesn't work
Democrats are using
black people they're using gay people
they're using minorities and it's been
going on for a long time well I thought
we'd flash back for a moment this is a
couple years back but it's a it's a
great great moment uh from the Democrat
debates remember when Joe Biden was
running against gay Pete and Kamala
Harris and that crazy socialist and that
other nut bag and the other guy and the
idiot remember that there was this great
moment when Tulsi gabbard really smacked
down Kamala Harris for what she was
doing as attorney general in California
related to black and brown people and
this is particularly interesting of
course because Kamala I guess she's
black she also says she celebrates
Kwanzaa she knows that Ukraine is small
and Russia is big and she's also always
pretending that she's out there like all
Democrats helping black people Tulsi
wasn't having it
I want to bring the conversation back to
the broken criminal justice system that
is disproportionately negatively
impacting black and brown people all
across this country today Senator Harris
says she's proud of her record as a
prosecutor and that she'll be a
prosecutor president but I'm deeply
concerned about this record
there are too many examples to cite but
she put over 1500 people in jail for
marijuana violations and then laughed
about it when she was asked if she ever
smoked marijuana
she blocked evidence
she blocked evidence that would have
freed an innocent man from Death Row
until the courts forced her to do so she
kept people in prison beyond their
sentences to use them as cheap labor for
the State of California and she fought
to keep tax fail system in place that
impacts poor people in the worst kind of
way thank you congresswoman Senator
Harris your response
the bottom line is Senator Harris when
you were in a position to make a
difference and an impact in these
people's lives you did not
okay so these are issues that we're told
the black community cares about right
like incarcerating people unfairly uh
keeping them in prison once they're
there for cheap labor etc etc and Kamala
was deeply tied to this when she was in
California and putting aside all the
issues for just a second like when you
watch that split screen man just think
about how different everything could be
right now had the Democrats done the
right thing and not gone completely
bananas left off the reservation imagine
if Joe Biden or whoever's in charge of
Joe Biden had chosen Tulsi as the VP and
she was the VP right now moderating the
party not going all in on identity
politics saying something that's roughly
true having half a brain cell Etc et
cetera how different that would be than
what they chose which was Kamala Harris
but you guys get it the the Democrats
have been doing this for a long long
time so we thought we'd flash you back
to something that some might argue is
not my proudest moment but some might
argue is my proudest moment I often
describe it as my best and worst career
moment at the exact same time this is
seven years ago when I was still a lefty
I was a Democrat I was a Bernie
supporter and I had
noted black conservative Larry Elder on
my show and we started talking about
systemic racism this has now been
clipped a gajillion times and seen by
billions of people black conservative
destroys white lib Dart not so fun when
you're that white libtard here is Larry
Elder explaining how the Democrats use
racism to Garner the black vote
get tell me what you think the most
systemic racist issue is what is it well
I would say that because black people in
most cases in many cases were
descendants of slaves that racism as a
as an institution that it's just two
thousand a certain amount of it just
exists 2015. give me the most blatant
racist example you can come up with
right now
um I think you could probably find
evidence that in general cops are that
cops are more willing to shoot if the uh
perpetrator is black what's your data
then what what's your basis for saying
that last year well look I know a lot of
people would say look what's going on I
know what they would say I'm talking
about what the facts are 965 people were
shot by cops last last year and killed
four percent of them were white cops
shooting unarmed blacks in in Chicago in
2011 21 people were shot and killed by
cops uh in 2015 there were seven uh in
Chicago which is a third black a third
white and a third Hispanic 70 of the
homicides are black on black about 40
per month almost 500 in the per year
last year in Chicago and 75 of them are
unsolved where is the black lives matter
on that the idea that a racist white cop
uh and shooting unarmed black people is
apparel to black people is BS is
complete and total BS there's where you
would say that this is purely because of
social justice purely because they want
ultimately for people to be angry enough
to just keep voting Democrats that's
right and where's where's the evidence
of a lack of social justice you know
it's funny I have to say no matter how
many times I've seen that clip or people
mention that clip to me which happens
multiple times a week when people see me
places I saw you with Larry Elder he
really smack you down it's like I feel
this odd sense of like there's a real
Pride there because right that was my
wake-up moment and then there's a
certain shame there because I wasn't
prepared uh what I'm really proud about
more than anything else is that Larry
and I for the last seven years I'm very
proud to call him a good friend who then
I've been on this adventure with but the
reason I show you that is you must
understand they pretend they care about
black people uh but then when a black
person goes out there and says something
they disagree with say a Larry Elder a
Candace Owens a Thomas Soul et cetera
Etc uh what do they do well you might
remember this LA Times this was when
Larry Elder decided to run for governor
against evil lizard person Gavin Newsom
Larry Elder is the black face of white
supremacy you've been warned so this is
exactly what they do you may also
remember the video we're not even going
to bother showing it to you now when
Larry Elder was campaigning in Venice
Venice California you know right outside
of L.A by the water over there on in
Malibu and Venice has been completely
overrun by drugs and homeless people and
everything else he's out there talking
about how you can fix some of these
things and a white leftist in a monkey
costume threw something at him somehow
you didn't see that on CNN and MSNBC and
everything else so the question really
is so why do black Americans vote for
Democrats there's a whole cultural
machine behind it they have just tricked
these people well number one they bribe
them with fairy tale policies here is
representative Corey Bush she is a
member of the squad and with all the
things that are let's say problematic in
the world today what does she want for
black people most Cold Hard Cash
United States has a moral and legal
obligation to provide reparations for
the enslavement of Africans black people
in our country cannot wait any longer
for our government to begin
addressing each and every one of the
extraordinary
bits of harm all of the harm it has
caused since the founding
yeah sorry lady no you're not getting
reparations not from me and not from
anybody else including California
governor Gavin Newsom who's been
promising them uh the entire time we'll
get to that in just a second but this
this concept of reparations that people
that have nothing to do with slavery no
one in my family ever owned slaves okay
and even if they did that would not be
my fault right you are not guilty for
your father or grandfather or
great-grandfather's sins if you want to
perpetuate racism you could punish white
people today take money from white
people and give it to black people who
did not suffer from slavery if you want
to perpetuate racism which actually is
what they want to do but to take money
from someone who has nothing to do with
what you perceive to be the problem
Generations ago is it's sort of racist
in and of itself and it just simply
doesn't work and it also just doesn't
show you anything about about human
nature but here's a little interesting
video about human nature this was making
the rounds of as people have been
talking about reparations again we've
you know people always say to me Dave
you always say these good things about
Florida you never say anything about
Florida that's negative can't you find
someone in Florida who's not making
sense and put them on the program and
then this morning Phoenix said Dave you
should watch this video here's a hearing
that they had in Tampa Florida over the
last couple days uh where a uh they were
talking about reparations and they were
letting people come up and explain why
they should get reparations and exactly
how much they should get here's uh one
such gentleman
all this nonsense homelessness and all
this other garbage y'all talk about
police violence and all this stuff don't
nobody care about that
don't nobody real care about that we
care about our reparations and we have
to put white people on notice
that we want our reparations that our
four parents and us we didn't work for
free and underpaid and all this nonsense
and the white folks get away with it and
they talk about the great city they're
building no we want our reparations
three million dollars per person
three million dollars per person right
here in this city that's the only thing
black people got to care about all this
other little nonsense y'all talk about
we do not care about
guys we're not going to talk about the
nonsense like you know homelessness in
our cities decaying and everything else
we want 3 million million in cash I like
how he just came up with that number was
that based on anything but it's such a
misunderstanding look I don't need to
make it about this one guy I think he's
an example of how people's priorities
have been bungled like if you want to
help this guy's life like let's say this
guy lives I'm assuming he lives in Tampa
this was the Tampa related event so if
if there's an area of Tampa let's say
that is economically depressed that he
would like to be fixed up a little bit
or they'd like less crime or whatever
there are ways to go about doing that
you could actually do things like cut
taxes which would then invite new
businesses to come in at the same time
you know you can't get upset when a
Starbucks comes in this is one of the
bigger problems you know like a
Starbucks will go to Harlem and people
say they're gentrifying and it's like no
you should want Starbucks to be there
because once Starbucks is there you get
another store in another store in
another store that's sort of a whole
separate issue but the the point is
they've confused people so that they're
not upset about the actual things going
in on in their life and in their
Community right at this very moment like
crime and drugs and homelessness and all
that they just want the cash and again
it's a fundamental misunderstanding of
human psychology if you think if you
give to that man and everyone else you
give them one million dollars two
million dollars three million dollars it
doesn't matter that then it's going to
wrap it up oh okay we're good to go we
signed off on the document guys no more
racism and generations behind us they'll
uh they'll be cool with this no the
generations behind them will call them
sellouts because they didn't get enough
cash that's how this thing works but the
point is the promises of reparation that
the Democrats have been offering for so
long are complete and utter BS so evil
lizard person and and I always say it
it's important to reiterate I believe
Gavin Newsom is actually an evil
cold-blooded reptilian alien wearing a
human outfit uh he has been pushing for
reparations forever then he wins
re-election and they bring him the docs
and they're like all right we're gonna
give about a million and a half to each
black person here and of course now he
doesn't want to do it we've got some
info from the daily wire California
Democratic governor Gavin Newsom praised
the work
he praised the work of his State's
appointed reparations task force which
he said had done important work to
advance systemic changes but stop short
of endorsing its recommendation for cash
payouts of up to 1.2 million Newsom who
appointed five of the nine members of
the task force told Fox News digital on
Tuesday that finding a way to address
the Legacy Left Behind the institution
of slavery was a complicated issue that
was about more much more than cash
payments according to a report from the
New York Post the total reparations bill
could land in the neighborhood of 800
billion more than doubling California's
annual budget look I just want to go on
the record as a former Californian the
California should do it and I think
every black person that wants to move to
California and cash in on these 1.2
million dollar checks should push Gavin
Newsom do it I also want to reiterate
it's very important to say Gavin Newsom
is a racist buffoon for not doing this
and he should feel the wrath of the
leftist activists now how about a black
Republican who doesn't seem to care
about this nonsense and cares about
working hard and education and getting
ahead and everything else and his life
is a living example of that well here is
Florida Congressman Byron Donald
smacking down Democrat Democrat activist
Chuck Todd on NBC talking about how uh
taxes are not for reparations they're
actually to fix things in society
if somehow you keep cutting taxes but
more Revenue comes in the government
that math doesn't work overtime you can
have it in the first first year due to
some various accounting uh tricks but it
doesn't work that is not true the
purpose of tax policy is to raise
revenue for the federal government not
to equalize Society after the Trump tax
cuts were passed more tax revenue has
come to the federal government that at
any other time in the history of our
nation those are the facts all Joe Biden
is trying to do is find every possible
nickel out of every couch from Every
American to pay for his radical spending
why would we do that now you may be
watching that going wait a minute wait a
minute how does that make sense Trump
cut taxes and then suddenly the
government got more money well you know
what happens guys when you have more
money in your pocket you start spending
more money than their sales tax and a
whole bunch more you start opening more
businesses then there's payroll tax and
a whole bunch more businesses start
putting more money into the economy that
when the government gets out of the way
that's when the economy chugs along
beautifully uh but Byron is of course
he's completely right it is not the job
of the government to take money from
some people to do what it wishes to
maybe make it seem like we all are
exactly the same that is not the job of
the government and you're gonna have to
kill you're gonna have to steal from an
awful lot of people and you have to kill
an awful lot of people to make that
happen which is why in communist and
socialist society so many people end up
dead
but why else does the black community
overwhelmingly vote for Democrats uh
well it's because of this constant
scaring they confuse you about the
issues right so first you're confused
about the issues you don't care about
the homelessness and the drugs in your
own Community you care more about
reparations and then they try to scare
the hell out of you uh this is the the
thing that's been going on for the last
48 hours the NAACP CEO his name is Derek
Johnson you saw one video yesterday
we're going to show you again in a
second but here he is further explaining
the naacp's travel warning to Florida
ah
major national Civil Rights group the
NAACP today issuing a travel advisory
for the State of Florida the
organization says that under Governor
Ron DeSantis the sunshine state has
become quote openly hostile toward
African-Americans people of color and
lgbtq plus individuals we're telling
Travelers beware
that you have a state and a state policy
landscape that can be harmful to your
existence okay it's just complete
nonsense like where do we go with this
like do I need to explain much more it's
complete nonsense there are no laws
stopping black people from doing
anything here we have more black owned
businesses in Florida than any other
state people are free here we have low
taxes we have good infrastructure we
fund our police right we got something
like 600 of the best New York City
police officers who fled New York City
which has a ton of crime that often
is related to coming from and the
victims are black they came down here to
Florida because we gave them five
thousand dollar bonuses so we have great
policing here it's just all working here
you you guys get that but they really
want to scare you and what is this all
about it's about this one AP
African-American studies course that
they also had included gender queer
Theory into uh so unless you think
Harriet Tubman was a lesbian pushing
those dikes through the Underground
Railroad something funny about dikes in
an underground railroad it works at a
technical level dikes because of well
you got it okay anyway here's the video
from yesterday we showed you this uh
this is him on CNN Derek Johnson he's
just got to scare you people
what they are saying is look
African-Americans and Hispanics are
doing quite well here when it comes to
running their own businesses and being
able to make money here and being able
to live decent lives how do you how do
you address that with this new ban
first of all that's propaganda language
reality is propaganda language it's
perfect this is 1984 man all right we've
got one more of this guy because he's
making the runs by the way I also want
to address you know when you see the way
they frame these things on the news so
the NAACP makes a ridiculous statement
like anyone put aside what your
political beliefs are anyone in their
right Minds knows that there is no
reason that black people cannot be in
Florida that gay people cannot be in
Florida et cetera Etc right we all know
that this is just the same old
fear-mongering as always but with the
NCAA does and and NCAA with the NAACP
does the NCAA probably does it too uh
what they do is they put out these
statements and then they know that CBS
News will lead with it right because it
goes against Florida thus it goes
against the scientists unless it goes
against Republicans okay fine so whoever
that anchor was the anchor in the yellow
is that nor is that Nora O'Donnell I'm
not sure who the anchor was like she
reads the statement as if it's fact you
know so that the double ACP this is what
they said they said part is pretty
racist here's the guy who said it and
then it makes people believe it's true
but it is all nonsense anywho the guy
continued is this one from MSNBC I think
so right he continued on MSNBC that
America will be unrecognizable in five
years because of the racism of Florida
ultimately what do you hope to
accomplish here
what is raising the consciousness of
people across the country it is making
sure that if individuals have to go to
Florida they know to be cautious but
more importantly to partnering with
groups on the ground this problem is a
result of an election
it would only be fixed as a result of an
election so we are preparing now for
future elections not only against
Governor DeSantis but other policy
makers who hold this point of view if we
don't stop this trend now we will not
have an American that's recognizable
five years from now well buddy I
actually agree with you on one thing I
hope we have an America that's not
recognizable in five years because it's
going to be a whole hell of a lot better
we're going to put people like you in
organizations like the naac be out of
business because you are you are
dragging racism to the Finish Line we're
we're over it we're done with it notice
they never bring up the specifics what's
happening with black people are they
being arrested more in Florida than
elsewhere are they being or they cannot
buy houses can they not own businesses
no it's all complete nonsense and
speaking of complete nonsense the NAACP
Fort Lauderdale president her name is
Marcia Ellison Fort Lauderdale one of
the only bastions of blue in this entire
State something ain't right over there
in Fort Lauderdale a little north of us
uh here she is saying that African
Americans are dying I think because of
DeSantis let's see
the fact that African-Americans
certainly are dying
um that our history is being erased and
that we are shown to have little value
is not a stunt to us the fight for our
very lives is obviously at the top of
the agenda oh propaganda so you see how
they do it uh black people are dying and
they show you a picture of DeSantis on
the side there history is being erased
not true you have to teach history you
have to teach civil rights and about MLK
and everything else again for the 80th
time this is about this one AP class
it's just complete nonsense but they
This Is How They launder the lies right
you have an organization a non-profit
organization gets money from whoever
they get the money from they say
something insane it then gets on the
news the news lies they rile up the base
it goes over and over and over but if
you think that was stupid
this might be the most insane clip we've
ever shown on this show you think this
might be it this might be it this might
be it this might maybe I'm going to
retire right after we show you this
thing what you were about to see and of
course it is from MSNBC is so patently
stupid ridiculous bananas give me
another adjective
horse shitty that you are going strap
yourself in here you go MSNBC here's
what's going on in Florida
Aisha this is I have talked for seven
years about the asymmetry of covering
trumpism in America something so
audacious and so unimaginable that the
normal ways of rapidly responding are
inadequate this seems to address that
asymmetry and
um and say I I got this what do you
think
I think it was extremely clever and I
really appreciate the naacp's guidance
uh on this issue you know I just took my
family to spring break in Florida
recently and I think about all of the
folks who traveled there for Sun and joy
and peace and restoration and to be
reminded that actually this is getting
to the point where Florida is about to
be a terror estate to many of us here in
America certainly as a lesbian as a
black woman I don't want to have
anything to do with the place
um and I think about all the other
people who don't want to travel there
either and so I think it was very clever
on behalf of the NAACP I thank them for
issuing this broad guidance and you know
really what it does is it turns a
remarkable uh I think lens on the United
States and highlights how bigotry and
bias and ignorance do as much harm as we
accuse other countries of doing to
people that they suppress
o m a g okay do you realize that that
black lesbian
just weeks ago took her family which I
assume includes her lesbian wife and
children to Florida for vacation where
they enjoyed Sun joy peace and
restoration then only because the NAACP
put out this statement she has now
realized that only weeks ago she was in
a terrorist state
it's so profoundly stupid it's so
profoundly dishonest that host Nicole
Wallace is an abject embarrassment I was
going to really go off on her on Twitter
yesterday but she doesn't have a Twitter
because she knows she's an abject
embarrassment completely ridiculous if
you ask that woman I think her name's
Aisha Mills if you ask her well did
anything happen to you on your lesbian
family vacation did anything negative
happen to you in Florida the answer
obviously is no now what's interesting
is that uh every year during spring
break because Florida is by far the
number one tourist destination of the
United States especially in the last
couple years we get an influx of people
and Miami Beach can get quite violent
there are all sorts of videos almost
exclusively of black people rampaging
through Miami Beach fighting with each
other break you know knocking through
drugstores and restaurants and
everything else it happens to be a
Democrat mayor in Miami Beach which is
uh why it's happening over in Miami
Beach Miami Beach by the way is separate
than Miami the city itself anyway it's
just it's a terrorist statement you know
I just would be like it would literally
be like you know I just took the family
to Gaza we had a great time I didn't
realize that there was a bunch of
terrorists over there except it would
end a little bit differently if I took
my family to Gaza you get it you get it
here's Byron Donald's again congressman
from Southwest Florida the Fort Myers
area uh shooting down this nonsense
utterly ridiculous nonsense from the N
double A CP
well the Miami Heat you know we're
beating down the Celtics last night in
Miami TNT was showing footage of
different boats in the water and on a
bunch of these different boats so black
people having a good time out on the
water I don't even know what the NAACP
is talking about this is silly and it's
dumb it's political it makes no sense we
should be focused on making sure people
actually have the opportunity to achieve
which Florida is actually doing and
thriving in way better than other states
let's say New York or California or
Washington State we're doing a
significantly better job helping black
Americans succeed and it's not just
about me it's about all the millions of
black people that live in our state
yeah true simple clean clear okay so why
is this happening right now well clearly
a bunch of this is directly related to
the DeSantis announcement that seems
imminent I don't know if it's gonna be
today tomorrow whatever we'll see what
happens on that but the clearly the
whole machine as we laid out quite uh I
would say quite tightly yesterday uh the
entire machine is aimed at DeSantis
right now so they want everybody to
think that the place that he governs is
racism Place 101 homophobia Place 201
etc etc but something else happened
yesterday I mentioned it earlier uh
South Carolina Senator Tim Scott who I
would say happens to be gay big goddamn
deal uh he announced that he is running
in 2024 and he invoked a line that you
may remember from another black guy who
wouldn't be liked very much by the NAACP
or the entire leftist establishment
these days
and for those of you who Wonder
if it's possible
for a broken kid
and a broken home
to rise beyond their circumstances
the answer is yes
[Applause]
for those of you you who wonder if
America is a racist country
take a look
at how people come together
oh
all together black ones and white ones
the red ones and red ones
working together
because love
unconditional love
binds hearts together
we are not defined by the color of our
skin we are defined by the content of
our character and if anyone tells you
anything different they're a lion
all right all right first up we gotta
clean something up here apparently I
just said that he happens to be gay uh
he happens to be black I have no
indication that he's gay uh apparently
the comment section blew up we've got
people Googling things I you know it was
a rare show that I didn't have to have
somebody uh Google who's gay today or
who has a penis there's no I don't think
the Tim Scott he's 57 years old he's
actually never been married lifelong
bachelor but I I don't know that he's
gay let's just get that out there of
course that's now going to be clipped
and there you go anyway he happens to be
black big damn deal and if he happened
to be gay big damn deal too the point is
that you could do whatever you want in
this country lordy lordy last time we
interviewed him there you go anyway he
he makes this announcement the machine
starts freaking out because what they
really don't want look Tim Scott is not
going to be the president but what they
really don't want is a bunch of
effective communicators that happen to
be black on stage during some of these
Republican debates Larry Elder is going
to be there by the way so now if you
have Larry Elder and Tim Scott making
these strong arguments it's going to
start waking people up and people are
going to be going wait a minute wait a
minute they keep telling me Florida's
racist and the south is racist he's he's
the only black Republican senator it
happens to be from a Southern state like
all of the nonsense will be on earth so
the machine has now got to try to
destroy Tim Scott so Chris Cuomo who
stepped down from seeing I know was
fired from CNN in shame apparently he's
got some show again and he had Cleveland
representative Nina Turner on and she's
a major race huckster and well don't
take my word for it here she is
do you think he has the ability to reach
into voters of color and say I don't
care what party you're for be for me
well of course one black face in a high
place does not mean that systemically
black people in America are not still
suffering so one you can attempt to be a
Unity candidate but the best way to be a
Unity candidate is by telling the truth
lying about this country's country
country's history gets you nowhere and I
am definitely appalled that Senators
Scott that he would even say something
like that
one black face does not God these people
these people they you see they they
resent people who get out there and get
theirs and become successful and do
things every young black person should
be looking at Tim Scott going man look
what this guy's accomplished and now
he's running for president how freaking
awesome how freaking awesome looking at
Larry Elder how freaking awesome the
Litany of people but every time that a
black person succeeds it is the leftist
machine and the people who have been
duped by it that try to destroy them
throw up the warning we're going to The
View
Whoopi Goldberg who has become a very
successful black woman who uh that's not
her real name I believe her real name is
Karen Johnson decided to take a Jewish
last name I don't know if that's
cultural appropriation or not she used
to be decent lost her mind you guys know
that listen to what she says about Tim
Scott right here
I think one of the issues that Tim Scott
has is that he seems to think because I
made it everyone can make it ignoring
again the fact that he is the exception
and not the rule and until he is the
rule then he can stop talking about
systems
he has Clarence Thomas syndrome
man you you these are not good people
look Sunny Hosten I know you know Sunny
hosten's not good he's the exception not
the rule well the rule all the rule can
be is that we can create a society
hopefully that gets out of the way
enough so everyone has an equal chance
and that's what we've got
you know and everyone could sit there
and complain about what their ancestors
went through every single every single
one of you watching this almost without
exception unless your parents your great
great grandparents were like Aristocrats
or before that they were kings and
queens and you could probably figure out
a way that they were oppressed to but
every single person watching this
wherever your great-grandparents came
your ancestors came from it was shitty
that's the whole point of America and
that these people then look at people
who succeed like Clarence Thomas
like Tim Scott Etc and they resent them
for that
they resent them for that
right like you shouldn't be on that
television show uh Sunny Hosten you are
an untalented unpleasant uh wench but
you're on that show and guess what it
has a little something to do with you
being black because if you were that
unpleasant and that uneducated and that
nasty as a white woman you wouldn't have
got the gig so you might want to look in
the mirror anyway this is unrelated to
anything else but here's Whoopi Goldberg
giving Sunny host on a lap dance I
apologize I don't know why we put this
in the show I just needed a break at
this point and again I just want to go
out there saying that Tim Scott not gay
as far as I know here's Whoopi giving
Sunny Hosten a lap dance uh there's
probably some lesbian reference but
whatever go
[Music]
no no
I know I'm doing it okay
well my behind's not that big first I
start out looking at you okay
[Applause]
and then I go back on the side
and wearing a lot less yeah
why did we do that
when we did the rundown for today's show
what were we thinking when we said we're
going to put that in there what was the
purpose what was the what are we doing
with our lives really guys what
anyway guys what I think we can do
is I do think we can beat this
Ridiculousness I really do think so uh
we can get good people out there to keep
telling the truth regardless of skin
color we can expose the hysterical
lunatics and when we are confronted with
new information we can learn a little
something from it let's flash back to
that moment with me and Larry Elder
seven years ago this is like a 10 second
clip and you can see me changing as this
conversation was happening
this is purely because of social justice
purely because they want ultimately for
people to be angry enough to just keep
voting Democrats that's right and
where's where's the evidence of the lack
of social justice so I was getting it in
real time back then that's why that
video went crazy the way it did and then
let's jump six years 2021 summer of 2021
Larry Elder then running
against Gavin Newsom to become governor
of California and you know who he had
open for him at some of his campaign
events well we got about a minute and a
half video showing you just that which I
just wanted to throw this in there
because that's the beauty of it it's not
just that we became friends then we
became ideologically aligned enough that
we went in and we're like let's freaking
fight together man
[Music]
nobody is sweating like Gavin Newsom
right this very moment
[Music]
thank you
Maxwell where are you I'm hanging with
your mom at the Larry Elder rally great
lady by the way really fantastic
[Music]
Gavin Newsom is tweeting this and he's
bringing in his spectacularly loved uh
surrogates like Elizabeth Warren and Amy
Klobuchar yeah
brought in a fake Native American from
Boston to tell us how we should live
okay and what they're afraid of is that
Larry Elder from the hood went to a
public school will be able to make the
case the black and brown people you are
being betrayed
manipulate
[Applause]
guys I'm only showing you that because
you know the recall didn't work but it
is worth fighting for what you believe
in it really is worth fighting if you
believe in and now Larry Elder is
running for president of the United
States and he's going to be on that
debate stage and even if it's only one
time but he gets his ideas allowed out a
little bit more uh how great is that
because you can change people's minds
your your experience if you if you
actually uh get it out there honestly
your experience can change people's
lives think how many people have woken
up because of Larry Elder right Larry
Elder son of a janitor from South
Central LA
and now look what he's doing I want to
give you some uh stats on uh on
interracial violent crime this this one
went up on Twitter from an account it's
a good account called end wokeness it's
interracial interracial violent crime
incidents uh in 2018 and let me just
read a couple from you a couple for you
here because I think it's going to shed
a little light on this black on white
crime there were 548
000 incidences black on Hispanic there
were 112 000 incidences white on black
sixty thousand white on Hispanic 207 000
Hispanic on white 365 and Hispanic on
black 45
000. it's interesting because Elon Musk
saw that and he tweeted odd why would
the media represent the real situation
to such an extreme degree and now I want
to link this to one other thing that's
happening uh that's been happening over
the last little while uh you might
remember the story of Brittany Greiner
she is a WNBA star who got caught up at
the Border in Russia because she had
weed on her and then she was held in a
Russian prison for a couple months she
is now back in America she played her
first basketball game about a week ago
they did not sell out because nobody
really cares about the WNBA and then of
course a bunch of people are saying that
was because it was racist and she
happens to be a lesbian so it was also
homophobic and whatever it's just that
people would rather see men play ball is
what it is that's a sidebar here because
Brittany Greiner who is now back in
America having seen what it is like in a
country like Russia she's kind of waking
up and I suspect she is going to be uh
turned on by the leftist media pretty
quickly here's some info from prox news
Brittany Greiner made her 2023 WNBA
regular season debut on Friday and the
seven time All-Star immediately made her
presence felt Greiner stood for the
national anthem before the tip-off
against the Los Angeles Sparks a 94-71
loss for the Mercury you have the right
to protest the right to be able to speak
out question Challenge and do all these
things Greiner said according to ESPN
what I went through and everything it
just means a little bit more to me now
so I just want to be able to stand I was
literally in a cage in Russia and could
not stand the way I wanted to just being
able to hear my national anthem see my
flag I definitely want to stand now
everybody that will not stand or come
out I totally support them a hundred
percent that's all right as an American
in this great country so I would say to
Brittany Griner I don't know any of your
political opinions but I suspect
Brittany Griner you are on your way the
path has already been laid out in front
of you and now you just have to follow
it you're going to be hated by all the
people that hate Larry Elder and all the
people that hate Tim Scott and Clarence
Thomas
but the truth will set you free that
ladies and gentlemen is where we are at
I'd like to say this was a tight show we
almost derailed it there were two
moments that could have derailed the
show The Accidental outing of Tim Scott
which again I have no evidence for uh he
is black according to the paperwork here
not gay if he is gay that's a separate
issue and will be addressed at the right
time but if and then why'd we show you
the whoopee thing
you know what we normally do our team
meetings on Mondays we're having a team
meeting immediately after this to
discuss why we showed them that and
saying what what why why
anyway guys tell the truth fight against
diversity equity and inclusion fight
against reparations fight against all of
the nonsensical people who want everyone
to be oppressed fight for freedom
and I don't know you'll just breathe a
little bit easier that's really what I
think all right we got a post game show
coming up for you in about 30 seconds at
reubenreport.locals.com my full
interview with Sean Spicer who just left
Newsmax by the way and guess what he's
going independent joined locals and we
got a whole bunch of other people that
will be announcing they're joining soon
like we really built something really
cool uh that is up on locals right now
part one's up on YouTube and Rumble we
leave you with Elon Musk hacking away at
a computer and we'll see everybody in
the post game show in just a moment
[Music]
come on
foreign
[Music]